okay all right Natasha how can we combat
the systematic undermining of media
institutions and that gross disregard
for a facts and truth yeah in three
words
just keep reporting on apologetically
keep speaking the truth fight
disinformation with facts and every time
the president lies or tells a
demonstrable falsehood as some people in
the media like to characterize it call
them out okay
Paul Begala what are your thoughts on
this year's Democratic candidates the
yeah the roster the bench how they doing
under you happy with the direction the
party is going in yes at first I think
they're great I've I'm out of the
business of running campaigns but I
volunteer a lot of these I've been all
around the country or you know for some
of these folks you got a lot of money
out of me and yes you help reelect our
president when I was working for him and
I was amazing I was so scared of Mitt
Romney yeah I gave Obama a million
dollars you know as she did now I would
give Mitt Romney a million dollars to
take over but we have more more women
running where people call it more
veterans sometimes all three you know
women of color who are veterans these
are this is a best crop of candidates
that I've seen in my life so my
follow-up question is how are the
Demerara it's gonna blow it actually I
have a good three words so you talked to
earlier with Bernie about what's this
look I think for the midterms this is
not for the president the midterms it's
really simple vote him out Willie came
up there really was speaking at a rally
and they were screwing about this in any
civil if you don't like it vote him out
not that that guy is way better a
political consultant and I am and he's
Willie Nelson so I mean I'm out I used
to work before the Russians were rigging
elections yeah that I use I the other
answer is don't talk about impeachment
that's just gonna drive Republican
turnout I mean you know I don't agree
with Sanders about it a lot but at least
he's talking about issues that matter to
normal people and it should not be a
campaign about the anxiety and anger of
the kind of media class in LA and
New York because that's a way to lose
you got to start appealing to people who
voted for Obama then voted for Trump and
now have to be brought back I agree you
can't be anti Trump you got to be pro
people yeah Lauren asked Charlemagne
since your next book is about fear and
anxiety what what do you think is the
number one issue we are we as a country
have to fear Oh
the easy answer would be Donald Trump
but I would say just prejudice in
general you know Martin Luther King jr.
once said he wanted he wants to live in
a country where people are judged by the
content of their character not the color
of their skin I think we need to broaden
that out and say not just the color of
your skin which is sexuality your gender
your religion if we can just eliminate
prejudice across the board and really
just treat people as people the country
be a better place not only I've only
voted how do you legislate that I mean
more than obviously than we mean we
mostly have laws in place already but as
a person that is governing you have to
be humane and you have to want justice
for all
right I think that you have those two
simple attributes it's pretty easy
regardless of what side you're on I know
I just think that it's very tough when
you get to that level where people just
don't vote for the right people well I
think it's gonna be easier after this
this this presidential term is over
because so many people have been exposed
like that's the beauty of this
presidential term like we nobody's being
covert with their racism and their
bigotry no more a lot of people are
being over with it so now we know who's
oh yeah
okay what are what effect will trumpism
have on future presidential let's not
talk about that [ __ ]
what do you think the NFL now that's
about him too the problem with this guy
is that you know he takes up all the
oxygen
it's just should the Democrats be making
the case that they rather than
Republicans and now the party of law and
order
rubba can certainly don't care about
lawlessness anymore that's you can add
that to the list of things they used to
care about and don't I was struck that's
the first thing senator Sanders said to
you and you know he said he's a
Democratic Socialist he's all about you
know Medicare for all and and and jobs
for all he didn't open with that with
you that's a tell what he said was
something you and I talked about the
real threat of this president is not
even any of the issues or ideas it's
that he's a wannabe autocrat he wants to
[ __ ] any checks on his power whether
it's the Free Press the federal
judiciary the FBI the CIA the opposition
party the Congress that's it's really
telling to me that somebody who's been
so focused on democratic socialism sees
actually democracy as the greater threat
from trumpet he's a hundred percent
right another slow-moving cool now to
set it before the elect yeah all right
thank you everybody thank you what is
your terrific